weiter geht es mit tetra sehe ich immer
noch mit meinem g35 und wir waren hier
gerade stehen geblieben dass wir uns
immer gegenseitig bei dieser band hier
so ein bisschen lotsen wo wir her müssen
sagt jedes mal den satz
mit meinem g35
zwei jetzt nach vorne ja ja und jetzt
gleich handeln
ja unter und wo wir jetzt mal nach oben
seien beim weiteren mann handeln jetzt
muss ich mal nach oben zu gucken oder
einfach springen vom handeln
so eine sache weil
so ich glaube alles nach vorne eins nach
oben hat jetzt noch einfacher jetzt ist
auch relativ einfach der auch noch jetzt
die 2
nein
sagt dann neben oder weil ich gar nicht
erst dran gekommen du weißt gar nicht
erst gekommen
nein
ja ich bin außerdem gesprintet nein das
macht noch mal
nötig um
kate anlauf
forest ich muss das jetzt kommt fragen
nicht wo er ist auch geguckt gut drauf
haben ja gott bist du schlecht ich bin
nicht gesprochen also ich hab das jetzt
aber
luca makes it mit einem jahr heute ja am
besten ist auch die kunst sprünge reim
machen genau so und jetzt gleich beim
ersten mal vergeben doch mit einer
pirouette
wartet ihr noch nicht gehen aber
nein
danke aber das muss einfach damit die
maus nach rechts drehen ja
ich glaub ich muss mit 60 fps aufnehmen
dann ist auch beim springen oder
aufnehmen flüssiger ich habe auf 30
begrenzt ja ich nehme mit 29,97 auf habe
ich auch eingestellt wird er 30
angezeigt aber
zu weit aha
schlecht
dann wäre nämlich nochmal flüssiger so
ja klar
batman hat man das
vielleicht mein individuelles keles der
ascon erstellen lassen oder könnt ihr
euch aber ich bin im werden damit
eigentlich ganz cool
so hangeln jetzt nach unten jetzt wieder
fangen die probleme noch unheilig haben
geguckt aber man das ist schwer
so wo wir es noch mal so und so und so
ich glaube wenn schon werde ich
irgendwann typ machen mit so einem
wetter richtig spyder
mit goldkettchen boka vorne drauf steht
kennt mich ja jetzt
nochmal oder nähe komme ich mache mache
ich
dachte waldkirchen mit luca sowie sind
vettweiß der das ist schon fast im hals
am boden schleift
sagt das ist böse die bilder irritieren
von nein auch gott jetzt fragt hatte ich
schon mal da
könnten witz erzählen so nebenbei fällt
etwas ein
und ich kann mir die guten witze merken
ja ich auch mir fallen jetzt mal so
schlechte mutter bezeichnete das war
kommt eine frau beim arzt
versteht da wo
keine ahnung das habe ich so viel witz
parat
ja das problem ist die meisten sind
nicht unter 18 freigegeben oder die
meisten kann ich mir einfach nicht
behalten man war so
nein a
doch immer die gleiche stelle gehe da
kommst du nie drüber danach wird's aber
echt extrem schwer deswegen kann
irgendwie fest aber auch egal so jetzt
sagen sagt danach wenn wir dabei pinken
sind da sind wir da wird sogar einfach
glücklich weil wir haben immer noch so
eine hier soll eine plattform wo wir
hier
drüber laufen können wenn wir verrechnen
so zerfällt wieder runter
sollen jetzt die
jetzt handeln
so und jetzt
nein warum geht das denn
du bist einfach schlecht
ich schaffe das jetzt
vor allem weil dann gibt es noch mal
zwei die gleichen stellen geld das ist
jetzt einmal das nach oben haken da geht
es wieder nach unten wieder nach oben an
die da unten wieder nach oben hangeln
wenn wir das problem ich habe dich
gehört deshalb echt klasse das park und
dann auf einmal was mit einem satz
weiterhin wenig text okay
du meinst es war zu schnell jetzt
schaffst du clos du schaffst das
ja mach jetzt in einem rutsch durch und
zwar so schnell wie es geht am besten
sodann da auch dann da hoch und dann da
hoch
aber irgendwie voll blöd wir schaffen
hier kaum was kann das sind wir so
schlecht oder was hat jemand von euch
endlich mal die map durchgezockt jetzt
die zuschauen habt ihr das gemacht
einfach so
keine ahnung ich glaube wir sind nicht
ich würde sagen wir sehen ich schlecht
dann falle ich habe am anfang runter
du willst du stellt für mein auge mit
dieser ansicht von opti fahren ja und
dann müssten ja wollen wir
ich weiß was du vor schlagen willst ich
möchte ja wort nicht in den mund ja ich
will
ja ich will
ich wurde oder ich habs jetzt einfach
mal eben so ja oder oder so aber glaube
ich nicht so ganz nach vorne
ok wo wollen wir hin da hätten auf bänke
bin ich schon fast dafür war ich hätte
nie den pass mal auf geht das ich glaube
nicht
vielleicht einfach mal eben so
machen
besser ja ja ja doch ja doch die idee
ist gut nimmt form an
weil ich denke darunter wirklich auch
noch mal das kann doch nicht sein dass
hier könnte man theoretisch hier einfach
das ist ja furchtbar
so jetzt bin ich drauf
das können wir hier hoch gehen
dann war auch hermann ich hasse das mit
solchen leid ich hasse das wort türen
und kakteen
ja
so wie komme ich überhaupt nicht klappt
mit der webcam hat sagt ja ich glaube
auch so weit gekommen jetzt hier wir
sind ja ebenso die typen die auf story
mäßige maps ja eigentlich schon spielen
so aber ich bin jetzt hier auf jeden
fall gemacht ich kann ja mal
falls es nicht schaffen sollte ist
ich habe doch leider hat ich hab ich hab
mich gerade so hoch gesetzt da weil ich
da nicht herumkommen um die einenkel
dass mit der leitung gemacht okay das
geht dann schon eher na klar schubst
mich komplett runter
komm mir nicht hoch ich habe auch nicht
auf die leute
mann ich bringe dagegen
auch das kann nicht sein
kann doch nicht sein wollen wir
rausgehen
die meisten anderen web rein andere
challenge erstmal hier raus
schauen was da noch so kommt ach so ja
klar
so war steht ihr tötet fleisch
buttons oder ideen hat vielleicht
bezüglich mitmenschen hat sich immer
spielen können story war sie jetzt der
kann das scannen die kommentare posten
oder eine pn schicken auch zur not so
was wie luchs perpetua genau die war
epischer wiese noch mal durch
wir haben aber nicht benutzt
bildungsstand jump nicht sprinten hier
dürfen war okay und
ist die letzte station zum glück
sondern tortoise folgen
es habe ich es geschafft ohne spenden
wohin jetzt achter
nein nein wo ist denn du du bist du okay
da ach da ja da hast du da und jetzt
also nach unten
die leiter nach oben dann war ich sollte
vielleicht überall hängen zum glück hab
ich bin auch nicht runter gefallen
ja
ich schon öfters er
jetzt müsste ich aufnehmen ich habe es
jetzt noch keinen fehler gemacht aber
man die uhr
die uhr sagt wir haben erst gerade mal
zehn okay weil du hast gesagt jetzt
müsste ich aufnehmen
ich musste jetzt aufnehmen weil ich die
noch gar nicht gefällt habe ist jetzt
ich bin stolz hier oben als ob mein
wunsch jetzt
entschieden
auch ohne sprinten
weiß ich gar nicht habe ich das mittel
ohnehin ja ja ich glaube doch könnte
seinen helm mohsen jetzt hin überhaupt
ich weiß nicht ich dann muss
warte mal ich guck mal bei dir
oh mein gott
na ja wieder darauf hörte
diesem fall der nach links zeigt
irgendwie
muss ich da oben drauf auf das dach da
naja ich glaube wieder auf die dinge ist
hier ja
gott ist so schlecht wie hier an genau
ja ich habe ja bisher alles geschafft
na klar
ich weiter komme ich nicht als hier so
war da komm ich nicht doch jetzt
darunter jetzt die leiterin
hier
so schön ist das gar nicht mehr
eigentlich gott nein ich jetzt weit
gelaufen
so ich bin noch drin
und maniche sprint den anfang aus
versehen tun halt nicht springen
ist schon eine tolle erfindung in
minecraft
zugleich schon wieder hier oben ja
ich komme jetzt auch nein noch nicht
wenn wir älter oberste kisten
unter der decke irgendwo
auf you have seen this before acht sagen
ja ich
sehe es aber ist das jetzt die letzte
stage sieht so aus
dass die letzte stage feuer oder in
springen wo der fall ist ich soll den
fackeln folgen
folge den fackeln folge den fackeln
ich habe mir den anfangs sprung hier
gottchen worüber können wir noch reden
das mag auch für nichts gute frage wir
müssen auch gesprächsthemen vorschlägen
dann könnt ihr gerne auch einreichen als
vorstieg bormann die kommentarfunktion
ist klar also einfach mal maps
reinschreiben ihnen wie in die richtung
von lux perpetua und andererseits auch
worüber sollten wir mal so reden also
jetzt nicht irgendwie redet über den
geburtstag von meiner oma sondern schon
irgendwie so allgemeinen fassende themen
die vielleicht auch ein bisschen was
keine ahnung youtube nachrichten so was
aktuell deshalb
irgendwie sowas in richtung
wäre vielleicht gut zu sagen können wir
uns darüber nämlich aus lassen uns den
mund darüber zerreißen
aber hier sind wir glaube ich er gerade
ruhig war deswegen konzentrieren möchte
nicht sagen weil ich habe den anfang
sprung nicht mehr aber hier geht's lang
und ich bin schon längst am ende und ich
checke als nicht wo ich lange muss ich
springe alles wieder zurück im kreis
aber dann muss hier entlang ist mich
noch eine treppe nach oben weiter meine
ich ja du hast und ich bin auf dem dach
warte ich hab jetzt auch ich
konzentriere mich jetzt
so ach so ich muss übrigens noch mich
selbst ein gamer zurücksetzen
er hat die ganze zeit weiter gesprungen
ja aber ich hab nicht geflogen oder so
was mir aufgefallen spricht man weiter
durch ein game auf
seiten des sprint ich bin es genauso
weit wie sonst auch
okay
jetzt nicht schaffe dann fliege ich
irgendwie zu die hoch- oder dann
teleport ich mich zu dir
steht schon auf dem dach und war so ein
kleines bisschen auf dich
ich sehe ich schaffe das jetzt
ach
so
und ob
da haben dann genau haben die helfer ist
schon die hälfte
ja so schwer ist das gar nicht mit den
fackeln bin ich
zu dir
zudem so dahin und jedenfalls die folge
ist auch schon wieder voll da sind jetzt
hier
ok ok ja ja ja dann würde ich sagen
nächste folge weissbarth morgen und in
der video antwort und wir sehen uns eher
er hinzu